bonsoir pierre martinet merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france une
troisième explosion aurait retenti sur
le correspondant de l'artère
internationales en afghanistan est ce
que vous avez des éléments pouvant
confirmer cette information
bonsoir absolument pas je la prends avec
vous et
ça ne serait pas
étonnant puisque il profite de la
pagaille pour kylie a pour déjà
commettre un double attentat c'est deux
explosions simultanées qui désorganise
totalement les secours qui panique
encore plus les les forces
occidentales et la population sur le
terrain donc une troisième c'est fort
possible après il faut faire attention
aux commandes de
fausses nouvelles et aux personnes qui
pensent avoir entendu ou qui pensent
avoir vu fois quand je pense à la
confirmation de cette de cette troisième
explosion
vous avez dit il désorganise il c'est
qui qui est l'auteur de cet attentat
pour washington il s'agirait de dèche
des talibans ont immédiatement condamné
les attaques et déplorent des victimes
oui j'ai eu aussi ou entendu aussi que
que l'état islamique avait formellement
dit qu'il n'avait pas du tout participé
à cette attente a donc il ya tellement
de force en afghanistan d
il peut y avoir aussi des tensions au
sein de deux au sein des talibans il
peut y avoir également des groupes de
l'état islamique qui ce soit qui ait
décidé de commettre un attentat soit de
leur propre initiative donc on n'a pas
exactement aujourd'hui de de
confirmation l'auteur comment est-ce que
ça pourra être al-qaïda aussi
j'ai des doutes sur les candidats parce
que je pense qu'al-qaïda et les taper le
et les talibans sont plutôt proches ils
ont été proches ne joue ce joujou je
vous rappelle que al-qaïda a été hébergé
et il avait refusé fin ils étaient
hébergés par le parler par les talibans
il ya une vingtaine d'années donc je
pense qu'ils sont peu plus proche bien
trop peur mais je vois plutôt aux dés
l'état islamique qui veut désorganisé
encore un peu plus le les talibans ou
démontré que les talibans sont les
nouveaux taliban entre guillemets ne
serait pas sur la bonne voie en en
faisant des concessions
les rapatriements vers l'étranger dure
depuis plus d'une semaine a maintenant
une douzaine de jours pourquoi ces
attaques terroristes interviennent
seulement maintenant
quand on fait le car le terrorisme n'a
pas de ne pas de calendrier je pense que
si c'était quelque chose de prévu est ce
qu'ils avaient prévu ça avant où ils ont
prévu ça juste au départ du lieu du du
désengagement et des rapatriements et vu
la panique qui a sur le terrain
actuellement il est très facile de
s'infiltrer avec des charges explosives
et des de faire des attentats de
commettre des attentats kamikazes donc
ils ont profité encore une fois delà de
la cohue de la panique de la
désorganisation totale qui a au sol il
suffit de voir des images j'y suis pas
bien évidemment mais il suffit de voir
des images au sol pour savoir que
quelqu'un qui se disent qu'ils se
déplaceraient avec de l'explosif est
absolument pas détectable
ssao mais la preuve le bilan est
catastrophique notamment pour les
militaires américains qui paye encore
allure un lourd tribut alors que alors
qu'ils se désengage c'est quand même
c'est quand même terrible ce qui se
passe les etats unis s'attendent à ce
que les attaques de sites continuent sur
une déclaration à l'instant du pentagone
continuer jusqu'à quand et dans quelle
mesure selon groupe
alors
prenons l'hypothèse que que l'état
islamique frappe aujourd'hui le l'état
islamique frappe aujourd'hui le
désengagement de
2 des américains et le rapatriement
bdd des afghans qui veulent fuir leur
pays ils vont frapper tant qu'ils seront
là ils vont frapper tant qu'ils auront
la possibilité de tuer des occidentaux
jeu
il faut rendre en afghanistan une fois
que les occidentaux sont partis ils
iront ils 0 les frapper ailleurs je
pense que aujourd'hui il profite encore
une fois de la dola de la
désorganisation totale et de la panique
qui se tient au sol mais ça va pas
s'arrêter là et après la fin de la vraie
question est est ce que
l'état islamique va entre guillemets se
rapprochait de des talibans va vouloir
encore déstabiliser le nouveau le nouvel
afghanistan
j'ai réparé par par ces talibans ou
alors ils vont
ils vont ils vont ils vont les frapper
pour essayer de de s'installer dans
cette danse est dans cet état qui
aujourd'hui
n'a pas de nom puisqu'il n'ya pas d'état
real il ya juste la charia qui est en
place dans les quartiers il ya des il y
as comment dirais-je des des talibans
qui qui qui gouvernent entre guillemets
dans les quartiers dans les régions où
il n'y a pas d'état constituaient donc
aujourd'hui pourquoi pourquoi l'état
islamique n'essaierai pas de ceux de
s'implanter jeu c'est vraiment une
hypothèse qui est qui qui est peu
probable mais difficile encore pour eux
vous avez dit lorsque les occidentaux
seront partis aisés seront d'attaqué
encore à l'étranger ça veut dire quoi il
ya des risques d'attentats en europe par
exemple en france ya beaucoup de
politiques qui s'interrogent sur le
risque d'infiltrations terroristes en
france avec toutes ces évacuations à
l'exécutif a évoqué hier via diabré
natale porte parole du gouvernement un
triple filtrage un triple filet de
sécurité à kaboul le départ puis abou
dhabi et enfin à paris est-ce que ce
risque est réel ou est ce que c'est une
polémique politicienne
alors je réponds à votre première
question le risque d'attentât et est
aujourd'hui possible partout je vous
rappelle qu'il ya le sahel aussi et
toute la zone sahélienne et est gangréné
par l'état islamique et entraîné par
tous les groupes islamistes et
environnée par al qaïda au maghreb enfin
je veux dire il est absolument
très dangereux c'est une zone qui est le
mali le burkina faso le niger c'est une
c'est vraiment une zone dangereuse pour
les occidentaux ensuite pour répondre à
votre deuxième question est ce qu on
craindre l'infiltration de entre
guillemets commando islamiste pour
commettre des attentats il n'y a pas
besoin de me de crâne de la filtration
les jantes ils sont déjà en europe les
gens qui sont prêts à commettre des
attentats au nom du projet islamiste
sont déjà en ordre
avoir une infiltration de grande
envergure de type
32 13 13 novembre où effectivement les
les terroristes ont utilisé les filières
de
clandestins de passeurs de clandestins
pour pouvoir s'infiltrer s'implanter en
sur la base arrière en belgique et venir
commettre des attentats à paris au stade
de france et au bataclan
c'est aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
difficile parce que tous les services de
renseignement européens se sont se sont
réorganisés contre cette menace là en
revanche ce qu'on oublie qu'il fasse
qu'on oublie donc on n'oublie pas à
point c'est qu'il y à une multitude
aujourd'hui deux candidats en europe
capables de commettre des attentats
individuellement ou collectivement alors
ça sera peut-être pas des attentats de
grandeur de la même grandeur que ceux du
13 novembre ou parce que le 13 novembre
on peut dire que c'est notre 11
septembre malheureusement en france mais
tuer quelqu'un avec un couteau une
voiture un camion on les a on les a en
france il faut pas oublier que la
majorité des
des attaques sont perpétrées par des par
des islamistes qui ont adhéré à ce
projet et dans ce projet il ya la partie
violente et la partie violente c'est
commettre des attentats mais il ya aussi
la partie une logique qui au quotidien
et est active quoi donc c'est un vaste
projet et l'avocat marseillais le
pentagone est en train de parler sur le
pentagone c'est sûr qu'il s'agit de
déchets washington menace même le groupe
etat islamique de représailles en
afghanistan bah oui mais le groupe etat
islamique n'existe pas en fait il n'y a
pas de terrain il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de pays islamiques aujourd'hui il
y avait un territoire entre la série le
l'irak ça a été militairement
détruit entre guillemets mais ils se
sont déplacés ils ont ils ont migré dans
la zone du pakistan et de l'afghanistan
ils sont ils sont en egypte qui sont
enfin visibles pendant les huit ans
ambre
en libye et au sahel donc si vous voulez
ils vont attaquer quoi ils vont attaquer
qui va je veux bien mais
cc
oui il faut combattre l'état islamique
il faut combattre les talibans il faut
combattre al qaïda y faut combattre
shebab les al shebab il faut combattre
en australie faut combattre
au nigeria aussi le djihadisme tout
simplement joël voilà tout simplement
ben en fait merci pierre martinet
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur de
wind corp security defence et ex agent
du service action de la dgse